اعلنت روسيا ان طائرات المسيره اوكرانيه
هاجمت عددا من مقاطعاتها بينها العاصمه
موسكو التي علقت حركه الطيران مؤقتا في
اثنين من مطاراتها بسبب تلك الهجمات
وتتزامن هجمات المسيرات الاوكرانيه التي
ازدادت حدتها في الفتره الاخيره مع تكثيف
استعداداتها لادخال طائرات اف 16
الامريكيه الى الحرب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كندا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات
ما دلاله تكثيف اوكرانيا هجماتها
بالطائرات المسيره على مقاطعات عده في
روسيا من بينها موسكو وكيف استقبل
الكريملان الرسائل من وراء هذه الهجمات
وما حدود التزام الغرب بتسليم اوكرانيا
مقاتلات اف 16 الامريكيه بعد الانتهاء من
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين وكيف سيؤثر
ذلك على مسار الصراع بين الغرب وروسيا
وكيف نقرا مستقبل الحرب في اوكرانيا
وانعكاساتها على المشهد الدولي والسلم
العالمي في ضوء استمرار الاطراف بالتصعيد
والزجي باسلحه نوعيه في المعارك الدائره
[موسيقى]
في اطار تصعيد فتحه هجوم على الكريم فيما
يؤير الماضي كثفت كياف هجماتها بالطائره
المسيره على مقاطعات مختلفه في روسيا
اخرها ما قالت السلطات الروسيه انها هجمات
بمسيرات اوكرانيه استهدفت مقاطعات عده
بينها العاصمه موسكو ورغم اعلان السلطات
الروسيه احباطها معظمه تلك الهجمات الا ان
هذا لم يمنع تعليق حركه الطيران في اثنين
من مطارات موسكو قبل استئنافها مجددا يذكر
ان وتيره هجمات المسيرات الاوكرانيه على
روسيا ارتفعت بشده خلال الفتره الماضيه
امر حضرت روسيا مرارا من تبعاته وتوعدت
بردود قاسيه عليها
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
موسكو اولغا
كراسياك من الاكاديميه او هي الاكاديميه
والمحلله السياسيه الروسيه
وينضم الينا من جيمس مورن الباحث في مركز
دراسه السياسه الاوروبيه ومن عمان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اهلا وسهلا بكم جميعا الى هذه الحلقه وهذا
النقاش ابدا معك في بروكسل
تكثيف هجمات كييف بالمسيرات على روسيا
والتي وصلت الى العاصمه موسكو ما الذي
تسعى لتحقيقه باتباع هذه الاستراتيجيه كما
سماها
اعتقد ان هذا
ياتي ضمن الطبيعه تذكير الشعب الروسي بان
الحرب سوف تؤثر عليهم هم ايضا طبعا هذه
الهجمات لا تتسبب بالكثير من الاضرار ولا
توقعوا الكثير من الخسائر مقارنه
بالهجمات الصاروخيه والسيارات الروسيه هذه
هجمات اوكرانيه لا تقارن حقيقه لكنها
بمثابه تذكير للشعب الروسي بان هناك حرب
مستعره ورغم كل ما يسمعونها في وسائل
الاعلام هناك حرب ستاتي اليه وستطالهم لكن
الاضرار كما قلنا لن تكون بتلك الدرجه
في موسكو كيف تلقت موسكو والرساله
ان كنت تسمعيننا كيف تستقبل روسيا هذه
الرسائل الاوكرانيه
تصدر لهذه الاوضاع بجديه
والاستنتاجات التي لدينا في روسيا هي اننا
علينا ان نطور قدرتنا في الدفاع الجوي
الالكتروني ان الهجمات بالمسيرات حتى وان
كانت غير قويه ومؤثره ولكن الاوضاع بحد
ذاتها جاده وفي هذا الضوء هذه الوسائل
لاسقاط هذه المسيرات هي ذات اهميه ولكن
يجب ان نفهم جيدا ان هذا جزء من الحرب
الاعلاميه الاوكرانيه وهي قد تظهر
للاوكرانيين ان اوكرانيا تفعل شيئا حتى
تقنع الفشل الذي
تصلها في العمليات المضاده لذلك موسكو هو
الهدف الاول كجزء من الحرب الاعلاميه
واللوحه التي يريدون ان يظهروها
ان يشعروا ان هناك حركه لهذا
النزاع تنتقل لروسيا ولكن في الواقع لا
شيء يحدث
كيف تنظر لتكثيف هجماتها بالمسيرات على
مسيرات عفوا على مواقع في روسيا منها
موسكو
يعني هناك جمله من الاسباب اول هذه
الاسباب القيود والخطوط الحمراء المفروضه
على توظيف السلاح الغربي داخل الجغرافيا
الروسيه وبالتالي كان البديل ان يتم
استخدام مقاربه من انتاج اوكرانيا
يضاف الى ذلك هناك ضائقه في ومعاناه بنقص
الذخائر
او هي مارس او غيرها فلا بد من التعويض
البعد البعد الثالث
دائره الحرب بالنسبه لروسيا عمليه عسكريه
خاصه ضمن شرق اوكرانيا بينما ما يجري هو
حاله حرب بالنسبه لاوكرانيا وعليها ان
تنقل الحرب الى ارض الخصم
فبدات هنا بمسار موازي يضاف الى ذلك تعثر
الهجوم المضاد اذا لابد من ايجاد مسار
موازي من اجل ادامه الحدث وادامه بعض
الضغوط على الجانب الروسي كان المخرج
الرئيسي استخدام المسيرات كبديل متاح
فبالتالي بدا يتم انتقاء الاهداف اتفق مع
ضيفك عندما قالت تاثير المادي محدود ولكن
التاثير غير المادي هو المطلوب هو المقصود
واعتقد ان تصريحات الرئيس السابق ميدفيديف
بالامس كانت تعبر عن الحاله
الفكريه والذهنيه ل القاده الروس بحيث كان
الازعاج واضح جدا من تصريح من كتابته
وتغريدته بما انه يجب
تقطيع اوصال اوكرانيا وتقسيم اوكرانيا
وانهاء اذا كان هناك تاثيرا وهذا التاثير
اضع في عده مفردات في البعد السياسي في
البعد الاقتصادي العسكري الامني طيب هذه
هذه المعطيات كلها ربما تدخل بقوه وبشكل
اكبر على دخول عنصر جديد وهو طائرات او
مقاتلات اف 16 على خط المواجهه وهنا دعنا
نذكر انه بعد نحو عام ونصف العام من بدايه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
وسايكييف المستمر للحصول على هذه الاسلحه
المتقدمه في مواجهتها مع موسكو بينها
مقاتلات اف 16 الامريكيه يكثف الرئيس
الاوكراني فلودي ميرسي
مساعيه للاسراعي بجلب تلك طائرات الى
بلاده وذلك بعد موافقه الولايات المتحده
على تسليم هولندا والدنمارك مقاتلات من
هذا الطراز الى اوكرانيا ففي زياره الى
الدنمارك التي قدم اليها من هولندا وقف
زيلينسكي على عدد المقاتلات التي ستتسلمها
بلاده وموعد ذلك التسليم مع العلم ان كيف
التي تسعى ايضا للحصول على مقاتلات
بريطانيه وسويديه وفرنسيه تؤكد ان
الاستعدادات لتشغيل المقاتلات الامريكيه
لن تكتمل قبل نهايه الخريف المقبل هنا
اتحول الى جيمس بورن في بروكسل هذا
الاصرار الاوكراني على الحصول على هذا
النوع من المقاتلات ما الذي يمكن ان يغير
ولا كيف تفسر هذا الاصرار وما الذي يمكن
ان يغيره على ارض المعركه
الامر المهم هنا والذي لم يتحدث عن
مقدمتكم
الامريكيون الذين هم بالطبع صانعوا هذه
الطائرات قد اعطى موافقتهم لهولندا
والدنمارك لتسليمه الطائرات الى
الاوكرانيين وانا واثق من ان نفس الموافقه
ستعطى لبلدان الاخرى هذا هو الامر المهم
لاننا حتى اللحظه لم نحصل على الموافقه
الرسميه للامريكيين وهو امر ضروري لكي
تنظر الامور قدما الامر الاخر متى نتوقع
وصول الطائرات
الكل
يرميله الى الاعتقاد بانه لن يكون ذلك قبل
نهايه هذا العام
والامر يحتاج الكثير من التكيف والتدريب
والصيانه وما الى ذلك حتى تصل وعندما تصل
هذه الطائرات هناك شك هل انها ستغير من
قواعد اللعبه
وستعطي الاوكرانين قدره اكبر على
الدفعهم ومجالهم الجوي حاليا هم لا
يستطيعون ذلك لان السلاح الجوي الروسي هو
الذي يهيمنه على السماء وهم بحاجه الى هذه
الطائرات لتعديل الموقف الامر الاخر يتعلق
بالشروط الشروط ايضا تتعلق بالقدرات
الهجوميه للطائرات وما يمكن اعطائه
للاوكرانيين لا يمكن ان يستخدم خارج نطاق
الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن على اتحاد لن تصل
هذه الطائرات قبل اشهر
لكن دعني اتوقف هنا فقط لاستوضح نقطه كنت
قد ذكرتها في بدايه جوابك وهو انه
الامريكيون يقدمون هذه المقاتلات مقاتلات
اف 16
للاوكرانيين يعطون الضوء الاخضر
للاوروبيين لتقديم هذه الطائرات
للاوكرانيين ولكن الامريكيون لا يمكن ان
يقدموا لهم هذه الطائرات وهي امريكيه
امريكيه صنع
كذلك هي مصنوعه في المتحده لكن في المقام
الاول الامريكيون يفضلون القيامه بذلك عن
طريق الحلفاء الاوروبيين هناك قلق في
واشنطن حول تقديمي واشنطن هذه الطائرات
بشكل مباشر لان الحسابات
الامريكيه تميل الى هذا الحذر لكن ربما
بعد اشهر قد غير الامريكيين موقفهم
ينتظرون ربما رؤيته وصول الطائرات من
اوروبا وما مدى تاثيرها في الموت في موسكو
كيف يمكن ان تواجهه روسيا هذا الامر
طائرات مقاتله امريكيه الصنع اف 16
ستكون متوفره وموجوده بعد التدريب في
اوكرانيا بعد حوالي سته اشهر لتضرب او
لتدخل على خط المواجهه كيف
يكون او كيف هو الموقف او رد الفعل الروسي
على هذا الامر
الروسي في هذا النزاع لن يتغير لدى روسيا
اهدافها ومصالحها التي تريد ان تحققها في
اوكرانيا ولن تتغير اما بالنسبه للاف سته
عشر المقاتلات الامريكيه اعتقد ان
الاوكرانيين يضعون الكثير من الامال على
هذه المقاتلات لماذا لانني لا اريد ان
اكرر هنا انه في العام الماضي كان
الاوكرانيين يقول نفس الشيء عن الهايمرز
او الجبلين وكانوا يقولوا ان الدبابات سوف
تساعدهم في الهجمات المضاده ولكننا نرى
الان ان كل هذه
المعدات هي هدف مشروع وشرعي للجيش الروسي
وفي هذا المعنى اعتقد ان مصير الاف 16
سيكون نفس مصير البارد ومختلف الاسلحه
التي تاتي من الدول الغربيه لذلك
لاوكرانيا قد تكون هذه الطائرات لها دور
رفع المعنويات النفسيه
ربما هناك تفكير ان الاف سته عشر سوف
تنقذهم ولكن هذه وجهه نظر ولكن في الواقع
في النزاع اتخاذا بعين الاعتبار كل عناصر
هذا النزاع لا اعتقد ان الاف سته عشر سوف
تغير اي شيء في الاوضاع او انها سوف تساعد
اوكرانيا لان روسيا متفوقه في كل المواقف
هل يبدو لك الامر هكذا فيس دويري انه لن
تغير شيئا دخول هذه الطائرات على الخط
ام انه هناك قيمه عمليه مضافه عمليه
وعسكريه مضافه لصالح اوكرانيا
يعني لا اعتقد ذلك ولكن هناك شروط يجب
توافرها اولا ميزان القوى من حيث القوى
الجويه ما بين الجانب الروسي والاوكراني
في الفتره الحاليه هي تقريبا تسعه الى
واحد 950 او 9 الى 970 طائره مقاتله
ومعترضه روسيه مقابل 176 طائره اوكرانيه
الان ما هو عدد هذه الطائرات التي التي
يتوقع وصولها الان تم الحديث عن 42 طائره
كدفعه اولى من دوله واحده وهناك دفعات
ماذا عن الدنمارك ماذا عن بقيه الدول
تحالف الطائرات 11 دوله انا اقول كوجهه
نظر عسكريه تحليليه يجب ان لا يقل عدد
الطائرات اف 16 التي تتسلمها
اوكرانيا ويكون لديها اطقم من الطيارين
والفنيين ومنظومات الصيانه والبنيه
التحتيه بصوره متكامله وجاهزه وفاعله عن
مئه طائره اذا توفر هذا الرقم ستحدث فرقا
نعم لن تستخدم في العمق الروسي لكن ستحقق
جزئيا التفوق الجوي المحلي واذا ما تحاء
اي بمعنى اخر ستحجم من المره الجويه
للطيران الروسي ولمنظومه الصواريخ الروسيه
لن تحقق تفوق جوي كامل لن تحقق سياده جويه
ستحقق سيطره جويه محليه و يعيد يعيد
الجانب الروسي حساباته في توظيف واستخدام
الطائرات وهذا ما تسعى له اوكرانيا سيحدث
فرقا ولكن بشروط العدد
والجاهزيه للطيارين وبقيه الاطقم ونظام
يعني هذا يدعوا للتساؤل انه ماذا تستعمل
او كانت تستعمل وما زالت الى الان
اوكرانيا يعني مقاتلات روسيه الصنع الى
هذه اللحظه
نعم لدي لدي 176 طائره ما بين طائرات ميج
وطائرات سوخوي ولكنها طائرات تعود الى
الجيل الثالث نحن نتحدث الان طائره سواء
كانت اف 16 هي تعتبر بلس يعني ليس الجيل
الرابع الجيل الرابع المطور كذلك هناك
الحديث عن طائر السويديه
وهي تعتبر كذلك من الجيل الرابع وهناك
حديث عن امكانيات التزويد وهي تناسب الحرب
الاوكرانيه اكثر من اف 16 في حال توفر هذه
الطائرات نعم لان ما تملكه هو يعود الى
الميج من الجيل الثالث وبدا يتاكل ولا
يقدم الكثير من المطلوب خاصه في المعارك
الجويه ضد سوخوي 35 وما شابهها طيب جيس
مورا
ما الحدود اذا لانه يعني واضح اننا يعني
اوكرانيا الان قطعت شوطا في موضوع التسلح
بالاسلحه المتطوره لكن الى اي مدى يمكن
للغرب الغرب ان يمضي في موضوع تزويد
اوكرانيا باسلحه متطوره واكثر تطورا من
هدف
استمرارا في رفع مستوى تقديمي المعدات الى
اوكرانيا من الغرب منذ العام الماضي الاف
سته عشر سوف تعطي درجه اعلى في سلم رفع
الكفاءات هذا ايضا لكن متى طبعا لا ادري
والى اي مدى نستمر لا ادري هذا يفتح
تساؤلات كثيره فيما يتعلق بالاسلحه
التقليديه اعتقد ان اللواء من عمان شرح
لنا الموقف بشكل كافي وهو محق في قوله بان
العدد يجب ان لا يقل عن 100 الطائره هذا
بالاضافه الى مستوى الجوده هذه الطائرات
الامريكيه هي اعلى جوده من معظم لا نقول
كل الطائرات الروسيه اضف ذلك فان الدفاع
عن المجال الجوي
الاوكراني توفر هذا الطائرات لكنها لن
تكون فاعله خارج حدود اوكرانيا هذا امر
مهم ينبغي ان نفهمه علاوه على ذلك الاسلحه
المضاده للجوال هايماس توفره للاوكرانين
درجه من
المقاومه والتصادره لكنها ليست كافيه فيما
يتعلق بموضوع المدفعيه انا افهمه من ومن
السياق ما يحدث في الرقه هنا في بروكسيل
ان هناك
امدادات كافيه من هذه الذخائر في الاشهر
المقبله وساستمر الامر على ذلك سيستمر على
ذلك ولكن هل الغرب مستعد لرفع السقف الى
100 طائره فما فوق برايك
نعم نعم اعتقد ان هذا ممكن وهذا هو
الهدف من وراء التحالف الطائرات اعتقد في
اوكرانيا ربما بحلوا لي الصيف المقبل او
نهايه صيف المقبل سيحصلون على هذا العدد
لاتمامي
استعداداتهم وايضا تصحيحا لمعلومه سابقه
هذه
الاسلحه حقيقه تضيف
تغييرا كبيرا في قدرات اوكرانيا الدفاعيه
اما بالنسبه للهجوم المضاد الامر في مازق
وستتوقع استمرار الهجوم مضاد على الاقل
حاليا القى كل هذا لا يعقد
الامر بالنسبه لموسكو التي كانت ربما
تتوقع حسما سريعا لمعركه لحرب كانت تسميها
عمليات عسكريه وبعد عام ونصف مازلنا امام
حرب يتطور فيها المستوى التسلح بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا
كذلك الحديث عن الاهداف التي وضعناها وهو
تامين الامن الروسي على الحدود مع
اوكرانيا ومنع توسيع النيتو
وروسيا لم تخطئ في حساباتها ان روسيا تقوم
بالاندماج مع هذه الظروف الجديده
والامكانيات الاوكرانيه تغيرت فعلا ولكننا
نفهم ان الجيش
الاوكراني هو معتمد تماما من التمويل
والمساعدات العسكريه من الدول الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده لذلك ما دام هناك رغبه
بان يقوموا بضرر ضد روسيا من قبل الدول
الاوروبيه سوف نستمر باعمالنا الحديث ليس
عن اوكرانيا بل الحديث هنا عن ان يضر
روسيا بقدر الامكان لذلك ان نقول ان
اوكرانيا هي قد تنتصر او ان لديها
مستقبل
ناجح لهجماتها المضاده لا اعتقد ان هذا
شيء ممكن ليس هناك حديث عن هذا الموضوع
الاهم هنا هو الاستمرار في هذا النزاع من
الجانب الغربي
قضيه الدبابات والمدفعيات والجنود ليس
عنصر حاسما هنا
ونتيجه النزاع سوف تحل على ارض المعركه
وهذا ما نراه روسيا قامت بزياده انتاجها
العسكري
والاقتصاد الروسي تقريبا بشكل كامل تعمل
على مساعده عسكريا بالوصول لاهدافنا
وروسيا لم تخطئ بمعدات
بحساباتها بل تاقلمت مع الظروف الجديده
لذلك الحديث عن اي فرص عن نجاح اوكرانيا
اعتقد شيء غير موجود
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
اولغا كراسينياك المحلله السياسيه الروسيه
استاذه العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه البحوث
الوطنيه كنت معنا من موسكو وشكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من بروكسل جيمس مستشار سابق لدائره
العمل الخارجي للاتحاد الاوروبي والباحث
في مركز دراسه السياسه دولي البلبيه ونشكر
ايضا ضيفنا من عمان فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا لكم جميعا والى
هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]